[Music]
[Applause]
he's a hall of famer he's a fox nfl
sunday analyst two-time super bowl champ
and i believe one of three coaches to
coach a national championship team and
also a super bowl winning team barry
switzer pete carroll i believe are the
other two jimmy johnson joins us is that
right jimmy
i i was the first one
[Laughter]
um the difference between coaching and
college in the nfl today as opposed to
when you did it is what
you know dan uh
uh not too awful long ago uh terry
bradshaw asked me on the show he said
what's the difference in college
coaching and pro coaching you know and
and coaching the game
i said you know
terry there's not a world of difference
there's a galaxy of difference
if you're really you can't compare
it
i mean i could go on and on and on
if you're in one of the top 10 programs
in college football
uh you know the difference in the talent
is so vast
you're going to win 10 games just by
showing up
so a lot of times it's hard to evaluate
a college coach going into pro football
the other thing is
you know
as opposed to grown men that are working
for a living
you know in college you're a mentor
you're a father figure you know they're
young kids that
left home for the first time in their
life
you know they've got all kinds of
problems girlfriend problems academic
problems you know they're homesick
and so you end up spending half your
time counseling them
uh in professional football
they're grown men working for a living
you know they have a job
uh and how well you do
uh depends on
how much money they're gonna make
uh so you know they're a little bit more
skeptical than a uh 18 year old kid
the length of the season oh now like i
said i could go on and on
you know the
i remember when steve spurrier went to
uh
the redskins
um he said okay you look at the practice
fields and he said well this is the
offensive practice field he said is that
the defensive practice field down there
they said hey you only got 53 players we
don't have we don't have no players to
have two you know two groups going it's
not like college where you've got 100
players
uh but there's a world of difference
between the two
where did urban go wrong
oh yeah you know i i
i think the mishaps have been chronicled
uh you know
quite a bit and i i don't want to pile
on uh
you know a lot of things happened uh
number one you know you know when i went
to the dallas cowboys
i took the staff with me that i had at
oklahoma state a lot of them had been
with me at university of pittsburgh
and but they were my oklahoma state
coaches and they were my university of
miami coaches they've been with me for
10 15 years
so you know there was never a [ __ ] in
the harbor you know you know if uh some
disgruntled veteran might say
hey we don't need to do it this way
well the entire staff would say hey wait
a minute we're going to do it the way
jimmy wants to do it you know so there
was never any discussion about how we
were going to do it it was one voice
with urban you know he had coaches from
all over
uh and you know
from reports you know there were you
know some dysfunction you know with the
coaching staff
um
it's you know it's a difficult thing you
know he took over
he took over a job but uh was difficult
a team that hadn't won but i did the
same thing in dallas you know people
don't realize
tom landry was one of the greatest
coaches of all time
but he had three straight losing seasons
and
not only three straight losing seasons
they had the worst record in the nfl
so it wasn't a matter of coaching it was
talent
and and that's the thing that i was able
to do is you know i was able to
jumpstart it with all those trades by
you know bringing in more talent
did you pick troy
yeah oh please i was in troy's home when
he was a sophomore in high school yeah
in fact i worked on troy for about three
years and he was going to commit to
oklahoma state
uh and then his last weekend he went and
visited oklahoma
he's going to throw the ball and he
stuck him in the whisper what do you
think happened that weekend jimmy with
troy
you know young college kids
it's like my oldest son was going to go
to stanford we were all set and he went
and visited texas the last weekend
fred acres called me and said hey jimmy
says you know brent just committed to
texas and my wife says oh no he didn't
he's going to stanford
[Laughter]
you know those last weekends
young kids that sometimes they can be
swayed you have coaches who are
successful in college and as you said
for a lot of them you win 10 games just
talent alone
but then you not that you get used to
losing but you have to be able to
sort of
accept it a little bit like you were you
were losing that first year i know you
don't want to lose but you can't let it
eat you up can you or did it uh
it it almost i mean i remember after
that
16th game i walked up my brenda bushnell
who did my tv show i brought her in from
miami with me up in fact i brought you
know the
you know the trainers the administrative
assistants uh the equipment people you
know i brought all of them to mine
because jerry fired everybody after we
got there
but uh
but i told brenda and she said hey well
coach i know that you're really down you
know i was just
physically and mentally drained
and she said but we can tape your tv
show tomorrow morning at nine o'clock i
said brenda
get one of the assistants to do it i
can't do it i said i'm gonna grab rhonda
and we're going to the bahamas i got to
get out of here
i mean it's it's difficult but now we
made some moves now we traded away our
only pro bowl player you know we we i
traded away the starting quarterback
steve paler to kansas city uh i released
the leading receiver so we made some
moves that probably cost us two or three
games
but i wasn't worried about that
particular year
i wanted to make sure we built a team
that could win in the future and in the
second year
had troy not hurt his shoulder we would
have probably made the playoffs the
second year
and so we were building for the future
but were you in jeopardy of getting
fired or quitting
oh please if if when i i've gotten fired
i've made more money than what i did
after five years because i had a 10-year
contract
might have had nine years of bonus for
the money
when's the last time you got a call to
coach
oh you know i i had quite a few
you know
obviously after i left dallas
and then i had quite a few
after i left fox uh
you know i had to make a decision
between philadelphia and tampa and
miami and you know i wanted to stay in
south florida i want to stay home so you
know i took the miami job even though
their cap was you know horrendous we
were five million over the cap when i
took the job
um
and then you know after i left the
dolphins
most of the calls then were to be
general manager or consultant or one
thing or another and i even had one team
one team called says you know come up
and run our draft
and i said what do you mean run your
drafts you come up and run the draft and
pick the players i said i can't do that
i said you know that's
i it take me three months to get you
know up to speed as far as the players
and i said i can't go up there and make
the decisions your general manager and
your head coach
they're not going to like that at all
you know and i said it won't work that
way plus you can't pay me enough money
to you know be away from home for three
months
so you told dan snyder know that you
wouldn't do it
i'm not divulging the team
he's uh jimmy johnson the hall of famer
joining us do cowboy quarterbacks get
too much credit or too much blame
well i i think the entire team and every
player on that team gets too much credit
and too much blame there's so much
visibility with the dallas cowboys uh
around the country around the world
um
every every week uh they're either the
greatest it's ever been or they're the
worst it's ever been
um yeah there's a lot of opinions on
every dallas cowboy
and that's the way it is and you just
accept that
you know when i left espn i didn't want
espn to be successful now i left on my
own but i don't know if after what
happened with dallas that you sort of
when you leave do you leave and go i
hope that they aren't successful
yeah no you know uh
there's a lot of people there that i
really care about yeah you know
you know i i've got a big stake in in
the dallas cowboys
uh and so i've got a legacy there that
you know i want the cowboys to win
you know i i pull for the cowboys
you know i i brought in rich dad ripple
even though he only worked for me i
brought him to university of miami and
then i brought him into the cowboys with
me you know and so there's a lot of
people that i really care about i want
them to win
um and you know and jerry and i have a
uh a strange relationship
but i want jerry to be successful i
wanted to win you know he's the greatest
businessman that's ever been but i
wanted to win you know another super
bowl
has jerry ever been on your boat
no uh
i i uh and i haven't been on his
[Laughter]
i think his boat's a little bigger than
yours isn't it
uh you had this quote about dak prescott
and uh you said he can win you a
championship if you've got really good
players around him
yeah i think there's a couple things
there um
you know i think
that prescott's
number one attribute is he is a great
leader
great leader for that team
and and you can say that about a lot of
quarterbacks number one
any quarterback's got to have good
players around you know to win a
championship any player has to have good
players around them but there are
certain quarterbacks
that could win more with less
aaron rodgers
needs a few good players but he doesn't
need a whole team of good players
um
yeah and uh
you know trent dilfer you know wasn't as
talented as zach prescott
but he won a super bowl because he had
an unbelievable defense
all right and so i think there's
it's everything's relative there i i
think that prescott is an outstanding
quarterback
uh but i do believe he needs you know an
outstanding defense and some great
players around him to win and i you know
right now he needs that running game to
get going so that he can take advantage
of play action passes and get the ball
to those great receivers it was about a
month ago maybe a little bit longer that
you said on the fox program that you'd
take justin herbert over patrick mahomes
yeah i've said that in fact i said that
about two years ago
you know when they were talking about
the draft i was on colin's show and this
is a week before the draft and they were
talking detroit was going to play take a
defensive back which they ended up
taking i said take the defensive back i
said if you'd rather have a defensive
back or franchise quarterback you tell
me yeah i said justin herbert take
justin herbert they said well you got
matthew stafford
i said i don't care if they i said i had
troy aikman and i touched steve walsh
you know
quarterbacks are valuable i ended up
trading steve walsh for a one two and a
three
i said you know let them have matthew
stafford let them bring in justin
herbert then they can make a decision
they can move one of them but let you
know hey a franchise quarterback is a
heck of a lot more
important than a defensive back the
other thing justin herbert he had
everything that i was looking for
yeah and he's not the most talented
quarterback in the league right now he's
not the best quarterback in the league
but as far as a guy that's only in his
second or third year
you know with his intelligence with his
ability with his arm
to build a football team i still say i
would take justin herbert
you know i love what i see with him i
thought it was going to take a little
longer to develop but what he's doing
has not happened before like you're
throwing over 30 touchdowns your first
two seasons in the nfl
and then he's only going to just get
better yeah you know as he gets more
experience he's going to get better
uh but uh yeah people criticized me for
saying that uh they're the second week
of the season yeah uh but and at that
time patrick mahomes was struggling a
little bit you know
he wanted to throw the ball down the
field obviously patrick mahomes is one
of the most talented quarterbacks i've
ever seen
uh but you know you know my homes has
had a couple of injuries you know
herbert is a big strong guy and uh
yeah i i liked what i saw
if you could take justin herbert or troy
aikman
well yeah i'm not real good at making
those kind of comparisons
not not with my buddy troy
[Laughter]
i think troy's okay with it
i tell you what you know
herbert reminds me a lot of both of them
very smart
both of them work extremely hard both of
them big and strong
both of them got a strong arm you know
and so hey they're comparable but i'm
not going to choose
so they're kind of like terry bradshaw
was when he played
uh now that's a different subject
but he is actually i recruit i helped
recruit terry bradshaw when he was a
senior in high school e.j lewis and i
sat in the stands at woodlawn high
school that was my first job coaching at
louisiana tech
and i watched terry play his senior year
and he ended up going to louisiana tech
but he was everybody's number one big
strong quarterback you could throw it
all over the field how did he end up at
louisiana tech
uh terry have to tell you that you know
he lived right there in shreveport and
in rustin it was only about 30 miles
away
so probably mama's boy and homesick and
wanted to stay close he's a he's
definitely a family family man you know
as far as his family
uh what do we
see about bill belichick or what do we
not see about bill belichick and what he
does because it
dad he's the best um but what what is it
though jimmy because you you're one of
my favorite one of the smartest you know
football people i've ever been around
but belichick
just does he seems to be on a different
level
well
we've been friends for
over 30 years back when he was at
cleveland we made a few trades and i was
at the kentucky derby with him uh 30
years ago
and he comes down quite often and you
know we visit on occasion
um
to give you an example you know one of
the times he came down here to the keys
and he's always got a little bit of an
agenda you know and you know i want to
go on the boat and drink beer
and we got on the boat and he started
talking about the draft
and you know he's saying you know jimmy
he said you know this and that we've got
some extra picks here and there
and
you know he started rattling off the
players that i had drafted when i was at
dallas he had already done his homework
and
and some of the guys i had forgotten
about he said you drafted those players
but your team was so good
that you know you you weren't able to
keep them they made another team you had
to cut them and they went to another
team i said bill
i said
draft picks are like currency they're
like money
and i said you know how every single
draft
you know
you're going to be in that round and
some you know there's going to be five
teams call you and say hey we'll treat
you trade you next year's two for your
three i said so bank some of those picks
you know that was one year that we
finished and then a year later he comes
down and he's talking about he's i got
three players that are wanting new
contracts
so and he started talking about some of
the contracts that we had done
so he's always working to get better
yeah you know i've sat with uh him and
linda and rhonda and i at a restaurant
you know here in the off-season he's on
the phone with with agents talking about
you know a free agent you know
we'll negotiate we'll do this and that
will he's always working
he's the best um
uh you know people want to compare great
coaches of all time
and obviously you look at the tom
landry's and the chuck knowles and the
don shula's and everything else but that
was a different era
i mean back then you built your team
that team stayed together for 10 years
you didn't have free agency you didn't
lose anybody
today's football
i mean you've got about 50 players or so
and you're not gonna have to you know
middle of the season you're not able to
have to take somebody off the street and
have him play that week
so i think it i think coaching is more
important today than it's ever been
you know used to you'd draft a rookie
he'd be on the bench for about three
years before he ever played
nowadays you draft a a rookie he's gonna
be playing it sometime during the year
so you know coaches have to be great
teachers
you know they have to be better teachers
than they've ever been
now they've got about 25 coaches now
they used to have about seven or eight
so they got a lot of teachers on their
staff how about a show beers with
beers on the boat with
so you you and you have
ditka
you know
you could have troy on there
maybe jerry one day belichick
i
i can help you produce this beers on the
boat
with
if i start listing
all of the general managers the owners
the the coaches the pro coaches the
college coaches that have come down here
yeah i've already had beers with most
all of them i mean you know everybody
bob mcnair cal mcnair tom benson
you know
john shaw
dean spanos has been down here two or
three times jeffrey lurie you know i
mean
you know and you know the same thing
with the head coaches you know i i
uh so i've had beers with most of them
anyway yeah but now we film it now we
film it and you guys know billy hey if
if we film it it's be about like what uh
david hill one of the great tv guys of
all time when he was there at fox
we have a production meeting on sunday
morning for about 15 minutes before we
go do the show
and we would laugh and cut up and tell
stories one thing and he said man this
is great this is great tv he brought a
camera in the next week
he didn't say a word
so you put a you put a camera on that
boat i don't think
uh it just means you have to drink more
beer
[Laughter]
everybody gets quiet when the red light
goes on it's uh great to talk to you
jimmy thank you happy holidays and uh we
appreciate you joining us all right dad
jimmy johnson hall of famer fox nfl
sunday analyst won a couple of super
bowls